qui sera plus fort que la miss vous
allez avoir une minute pour répondre aux
plus de questions de culture générale
possible et on fera la même chose avec
les chroniqueurs on va démarrer qui est
chroniqueur d'accord et on va voir qui
va répondre plus de questions une minute
pour les chroniqueurs je rappelle c'est
un test de culture générale
maxi nous a le droit de dire je passe
les chroniqueurs bien sûr c'est l'un
après l'autre bout une ici et après ce
sera que clémence attention pas avec le
jaune et le bleu qu'elle est la
troisième des couleurs primaires
beinheim rouge rouge bonnes réponses
citées de membres du futur jury de the
voice the wolf marc lavoine et amel bent
très bien qu'élevé novelli cité un
membre de jean michel maire un combat
très bon balle réponse quelle chaîne se
trouve sur le canal 18 de la tnt vous
nous taksim gagner ses news non philippe
dulieu signifie des lettres a b présente
sur l'emballage de certains produits
alimentaires isabelle morini-bosc année
c'est agriculture biologique bras d'eau
qu'est-ce qui peut être que de pain de
tambours ou de sourcier géraldine la
baguette
je vais vous faut allier m m6 va
prochainement lancer une émission de
magie où karine le marchand va essayer
de faire disparaître les téléspectateurs
est bien vrai mais je vais dire
chauffe-eau combien font 8 x 5 1 40
ouais ou calme-toi de trois lettres
désignent la mamelle d'une vache
médaille me pique très bonne de quelle
couleur et le jdd personnes qui
manifestent en france en ce moment que
je n'ai pas de réponse alors attention à
voir combien vous avez de bonnes
réponses
non si on a beaucoup plus apparemment en
régie tient pas compte et un an mais
sans rigoler ils ont un truc à faire
c'est à hub et naïm ya urgence n 1 2 3 5
6 7 9 8 9
il ya eu neuf 9 de réponse 1,6 et une
autre bonne raison ils me disent non des
phénomènes et benhalima beria 1 2 3
isabelle 4 5 ayem si c'est mon 7 et 8 il
me dit cissé sont personae cette vente
de remords
kimathi attention on va jouer maintenant
avec clémence clément vous avez huit
bonnes réponses à battre j'espère que
vous allez les défoncer clémence
attention c'est parti
quel nom donne ton aux habitants de la
nouvelle zélande les calédoniens non les
néo zélandaise et qu'est ce qui peut
être de billard de pie ou encore de
cheval des pierres depuis vous faut dans
danse avec les stars il ya plus de danse
que deux stars oui à puiser dans ce
qu'elle cité française est surnommée la
ville rose night ce qui est pour moi la
fille de la soeur de mon père la fille
la soeur de mon père c'est bouchra non
c'est ma cousine
combien y at-il de g dans une tonne 1000
1 million et un million deux derniers
livres des frères bogdanov a pour titre
le visage de dieu où nous ne mentons
jamais le visage radieux de quel pays
est originaire la bossa nova le brésil
oui quel est le prénom d'antoine
griezmann en paix louis de quoi ai je
peur si je suis mise au four big lots
mis aux phobiques mise dans une bâche
louis de la soupe miso
non c'est de la saleté des microbes
parce que j'ai le meilleur christophe
castaner ou à l'extérieur c'est bien sûr
qu'ils savent que c'est à dire ouais
franchement ouais voilà gagné s'est
passé il ya eu sur il est plus facile
merci on peut le dire c'est bien
[Applaudissements]